hello everyone so welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily it's always
been my dream to be a speaker and with
the help of Evan I'm able to do this
full-time and you guys are all coming
along for the ride with me
so Evan challenge for you to research 20
speakers and the reason for that is I'm
starting out on my journey and the truth
is I can't figure everything out on my
own but it will take me a very very long
time
so to shorten that process it's
important for me to take a look at all
the people who have done similar things
to what I want to do and I can look at
their path so that way I could
fast-track my process and a model after
them so I needed 20 speaker I only had
three three people have been following
for the past few years but I needed 17
more how do I do that right so I thought
to myself all you know what Evan
actually covers a lot of successful
people on his channel I'm sure some of
them are speakers and it's true I did
find a lot of them on his channel but I
needed more than that and Google being
our best friends I actually would be
Google's famous speakers and I was able
to come up with my list of 20 names and
once I got their 20 names I split the
research into two parts so I had one
part which was a path to success and the
other part is their business side so the
path to success is very crucial the
reason for that is right now I'm just
starting which for me to compare my
beginning to their top is what they're
doing right now seems like it's way too
much of a leap and it almost seems
impossible at times but if I were to
actually look at all the things that
they have done in the previous years and
when they first got started it not only
doesn't make it more realistic for me
but also makes more sense now okay these
are the things that I need to do to get
to where they are today
and on the business side I want to be
able to make an income from speaking so
for me to look at all the things that
you're doing to earn an income is going
to help me create a business around
speaking as well so as part of my
research I needed to highlight their
breakthrough so what are the specific
things that they did to break them
through into the success as they are
today and as I was doing my research I
started to realize that there were three
common ways that they were breaking
through so the first one is to find a
kingmaker so what that means is to
leverage an existing brand or media so
for example Oprah Winfrey and Les Brown
where has mediocre success but they
didn't actually become household name
until they have their own talk shows and
even Jack Canfield who used to be an
educator and he didn't actually become
known for what he is today until he
published his first book in his Chicken
Soup for the Soul series number two is
to grind out content is to work
consistently on your craft day after day
after day so you have Neil passed Rita
who wrote on his blog a thousand awesome
things every single day until one day he
was recognized and he was able to get a
book deal out of it which is the book of
awesome and Eric Thomas who put out
YouTube videos after YouTube videos
after YouTube videos until one of them
went viral and had over 40 million views
and number three is to prove it live
these are the folks that went on stage
and actually proved themselves and their
message and stood up for what they
believed in so you have Tony Robbins who
was well known but did not become
notorious until he went on stage and
cured a woman from her snake phobia
after being challenged by psychiatrists
that he was a sane and even Bernie Brown
and simon Sinek
were relatively unknown before they had
their world popular TEDx talk which
actually put them on the map as being
the leading thought leader so the
business side I was able to identify
three common ways they were making an
income so number one our online training
program so Sean actually
we Oberstein and Zig Ziglar all have
online courses that they fell through
their website number two our books Lisa
Nichols Robin Sharma and Dale Carnegie
all Rose bestsellers has sold millions
of copies number three our live events
and seminars Tony Robbins Brenda
Bouchard and Eckhart Tolle all sell out
their shows months leading up to their
live event so I walked into this
research knowing I wanted to be a
speaker but I'm walking away so much
more clarity on the briefing aside I
love the people that proved it live
there's something so magical and
exhilarating to me about going onstage
and showing yourself showing up as
yourself and standing up for what you
believe in and proving yourselves
improving your message so I really want
to focus my energy into doing that and
on the business side I love coaching I
love the one-on-one connection that I
get with people not only that to see
them being inspired by their own
awesomeness and going out there and
doing amazing things with taking action
so I'm going to focus a lot of my energy
into coaching and as much as I love the
one-on-one connection that I get from
coaching I love a group environment as
well
there's something so fulfilling to me
when I see a group of people support
each other and have empathy for each
other and then walk away as a group
feeling you know completely inspired and
ready to like take on their goals it's
such an amazing feeling so on the
business side I'm going to really focus
a lot of my time into the coaching and
the workshops side so this research gave
me so much more than just a path to
becoming a speaker it gave me confidence
a lot of the times I think to myself but
maybe my goal is to bold maybe I can't
get there maybe it's a silly idea you
know what makes me think that I could
actually achieve the same amount of
success as all these people did you know
maybe I should have started when I was a
lot younger I don't have a lot of time
I need more education I need to go back
to school I need to go get a PhD until
that happens I can't actually go on
stage and give a speech because I don't
know what I'm talking about or I feel
like I don't have the money to back up
this business plan that I have and the
truth is a lot of these people that are
researched start off with a lot less
than what I have right now I already
have way more you know look at Dale
Carnegie
she was actually homeless when he
started off his first seminar he was
living at the YMCA and the things that
he's accomplished from having so little
is incredible even years and years after
his passing people know his training
program they know his books his book is
still one of the bestsellers in the
world so what gives me the excuse at the
same time it makes me feel very
confident if he can do it so can i and
that's really this is write anything
that you want to do is not too bold
because people who have done it before
you have done it with a lot less so for
my next challenge I'm going to take you
guys on a deeper journey into the three
people that I resonated with the most so
they are Tony Robbins brynee Brown and
simon Sinek I'm going to share with you
what are the specific things that they
did to get to where they are today and
also what are the things that I have
learned from them that I could put into
action right away so the question of the
day is who are the three people that you
look up to in your industry that you
know start researching today I love
reading your comments and I would love
to find out who they are so leave in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
on the discussion so thank you so much
for watching but more importantly I am
so grateful for having you on this
journey with me
you have been so supportive and
encouraging and loving since day one and
honestly I couldn't have asked for a
better community than the leaf nation to
be part of this pretty ride I'm awed and
actually have a special shout out for
Karthik ready
so Karthik
out Lilly you improved Lilly
congratulations
so Karthik thank you so much for writing
the encouraging kind words it really
does mean a lot to me so thank you and
thank you guys and I'll see you very
very soon for another episode of
unlocking Lilly thank you and love you
all